رفضت الخارجيه الايرانيه اتهام طهران
بالوقوف وراء استهداف القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه وقالت ان قوات المقاومه في
المنطقه لا تتلقى الاوامر من طهران وتتخذ
قراراتها للدفاع عن الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل
مستقل واعتبرت الخارجيه الايرانيه اتهام
ايران بالوقوف وراء هذه العمليه اتهاما
باطلا ومحاوله لجر واشنطن الى معركه جديده
في المنطقه واكدت طهران انها حذرت مرارا
من خطوره توسيع دائره الصراع بسبب استمرار
الهجمات الاسرائيليه على غزه الخارجيه
الايرانيه شددت على ان وقف اطلاق اطلاق
النار في غزه سيماد الطريق امام عوده
الهدوء الى المنطقه مؤكده اهميه الحفاظ
على السلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه معنا من طهران مراسل الجزيره عمر
هواش اهلا بك عمر لو تقربنا اكثر من هذا
الموقف الذي عبرت عنه الخارجيه الايرانيه
والذي يرفض الاتهامات الامريكيه بالوقوف
وراء هذا
الهجوم نعم سهام طهران ترفض الاتهامات
التي وجهت لها
بالمسؤوليه عن الهجوم الذي تعرضت له
القوات الامريكيه يوم امس ه جاء هذا النفي
اولا على لسان الممثليه الايرانيه في
الامم المتحده التي قالت انه لا علاقه لها
بهكذا هجمات على القوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه وان هكذا هجمات هي تادي في اطار
الفعل ورد الفعل بين الجيش الامريكي ومن
تسميهم طهران قوات المقاومه في المنطقه
اليوم الخارجيه الايرانيه ايضا اكدت هذا
النفي بل وزادت ان ايران لا يمكنها ان
تتدخل لمنع ما وصفها بدفاع هذه الفصائل
المقاومه عن نفسها او بدعم الشعب الفلسط
فلسطيني تجاه ما يجري في قطاع غزه كذلك
قالت الخارجيه ان القوات المقاومه في
المنطقه لا تتلقى الاوامر من طهران وذكرت
الخارجيه بان طهران دائما شددت على ان ان
الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل في حربه على غزه
من شانه ان يعزز زعزعه الاستقرار ويوسع
دائره الصراع في المنطقه ويوسع رقعه الحرب
طهران تذكر اليوم بهذا التحذير و تقول ان
هناك معادله بسيطه من شانها ان توقف دائره
الصراع في المنطقه الا وهي ان ايقاف الحرب
على غزه ايقاف الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل في
هذه الحرب يمكن ان يقابل
ب اعاده الاستقرار للمنطقه وقف هكذا هجمات
على القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه من قبل
فصائل المقاومه سواء في العراق او في
سوريا او حتى كذلك كانت قد قالت ان ال
الهجمات الحوثيه في اليمن ضد سفن في البحر
الاحمر ايضا مرتبطه بالحرب على غزه وان
ايقاف الحرب على غزه كذلك يمكن ان يعيد
الهدوء والتوتر الى البحر الاحمر وهذا
الامر ايضا تعيد وتقول انه انه يمكن ان
يتم تطبيقه على القوات الامريكيه في سوريا
والعراق كانت طهران قد اكدت اكثر من مره
انها تبادلت الرسائل مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عبر اكثر من وسيط من بينهم
السفاره السويسريه في طهران راعيه المصالح
الامريكيه بان على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان توقف دعمها لاسرائيل وان على
اسرائيل ان توقف حربها على غزه اذا اراد
الجميع ان يعود الاستقرار للمنطقه وان
طهران لا تريد توسيع دائره الصراع لا تريد
ان يتم زعزعه الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
لانها جزء من المنطقه وتؤكد طهران دائما
على ان الحضور الامريكي في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط في منطقه غرب اسيا كما تسميها هو
عامل لزعزع الامن والاستقرار ولا يمكن ان
يوفر الامن ويضمن الامن لهذه الدول وان
الدول بنفسها يمكنها ان تحقق الامن
والاستقرار الاقليمي اذا هناك معادله تؤكد
طهران اليوم عليها بان ايقاف الحرب على
غزه ايقاف الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل في هذه
الحرب يمكن ان يؤدي الى عوده الاستقرار
الى المنطقه وبالتالي الهجمات
الامريكيه هجمات بعض فصائل المقاومه
العراقيه على القوات الامريكيه سواء في
العراق او في سوريا شكرا لك عمر هواش
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من طهران